[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Right,
well, good afternoon.
And welcome to a very
special Talks at Google.
I am delighted to have the three
principals from "Wicked" here.
We've got Sophie Evans,
who plays Glinda.
Give it up for Sophie.
[APPLAUSE]
Sophie's mom is also here today.
So we're very glad that
everyone can see her.
SOPHIE EVANS: Yay!
Thank you, Mummy.
SPEAKER: Alice Fearn,
who plays Elphaba.
[APPLAUSE]
It was Alice's
birthday yesterday,
so we can maybe sing
"Happy Birthday" later.
And we've got Bradley
Jaden, who plays Fiyero.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't have a fun
fact about you Bradley.
So maybe you can fill one in.
BRADLEY JADEN: Oh, fun fact?
SPEAKER: Fun fact, exactly.
Right from the get go.
AUDIENCE: I've got
really long hair.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
So the way that today's
event is going to work
is we've got 45
minutes with the cast.
We'll open it up to
questions halfway.
As Rob said, there's a
microphone in the middle.
So please get ready to
go with your questions.
I'll let you know when it's
time to start moving there.
And then afterwards, there's
the opportunity for some photos.
We've got props at the back,
which I think most of you
have already seen.
I'm really excited about today.
So I'm going to start with a
quick overview of, I guess,
"The Wizard of Oz" universe.
In 1900, Frank
Baum writes a book.
In 1939, we've got
the famous film
with Dorothy and Toto and
her ruby red slippers.
And then we flip to the
witch's perspective in 1995,
with the novel "Wicked, The Life
and Times of the Wicked Witch
of the West," which turns into
the musical that you all know
and love, "Wicked, The Untold
Stories of the Witches of Oz "
So first of all, these are
some iconic characters.
And they have been
originated by legends--
Idina Menzel, Kristin Chenoweth,
who was in London recently.
And I'd love to hear
about what that was like.
But how do you work within the
existing "Wicked" universe?
How do you do this?
How do you take these characters
and really make them your own?
ALICE FEARN: I think it's--
I think for me, anyway, it's
quite simply just whenever
I have ever played something
that is iconic or has been
played before by
other people, I think
you just go back to the
book, the story, what
was originally written.
And I think you,
from there, find
your version of
that person and why
she reacts or he reacts
in whatever ways you--
from what you read and what
you learn from that person.
So, I think then,
you're not controlled
by people that have
done it before,
or the way that
they've played it.
And in fact, what
you do is create
your own version of of them.
And I think then,
they become very true.
I think they're very real.
People can relate to
that person quite well.
So, I think as long
as you go back--
just go back to the script
and go back to the words
and what was written
originally, and I don't think
you can go that far wrong.
SPEAKER: I love it.
With Kristin in the
audience last week--
SOPHIE EVANS: Yes.
That was crazy.
Because, as a teenager,
she was the lady
that I listened to
singing popular.
And I wanted to be
exactly like her.
And with her being
in the audience,
I probably did put a few Kristin
Chenoweth accents on everything
because I just think the way
she did it was fantastic.
But yeah, like Alice said,
it's keeping everything
that was there originally, but
bringing yourself to the role
as well.
Because you don't want to see
a carbon copy every single time
you go and see a show.
It's nice to see someone's
personality injected
into the character.
SPEAKER: So what do
you think you bring
that's unique to the role?
SOPHIE EVANS: I think I bring--
I try to be really truthful.
I'm very clumsy in
life in general.
So I bring that kind
of ditziness to it
quite naturally.
SPEAKER: Is that true, Mum?
Yes, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
SOPHIE EVANS: I'm
a baby giraffe.
I fall over all the time.
So that's great.
But yeah, keeping the truth
of Glinda, and everything is--
it comes from a good place
even though something she says
might come across as a
little bit catty or not quite
what it seems.
But it does always come
from a truthful, good place.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
And Bradley, you've worked
not only here in London,
but you've actually
been part of some
of the international casts.
So how do you, I guess,
bring your truth to the role?
BRADLEY JADEN: I think,
like Alice said--
she answered it really well.
I don't think
trying to replicate
anyone else is going to do
yourself justice or the piece.
And we're very thankful
that we are working
with such an incredible piece,
both with lyrics and dialogue,
every night.
So as long as we are telling
the story in our own way,
and telling it as truthfully
as we possibly can,
then the job's pretty
much halfway there.
Of course, we have our
own little touches.
Me having long hair, I don't
think that's happened before.
[LAUGHTER]
ALICE FEARN: "Toss
Toss" gets an extra--
BRADLEY JADEN: Yeah,
the "Toss Toss"
is slightly different now.
But yeah, it's about
having fun and making
sure you're telling the
story and telling the truth.
And I think as long as you
do do that, the audience are
going to follow you hopefully.
So--
SPEAKER: I love that
all three of you
have touched on this
idea of truthfulness,
right, and being true to
yourself, but also true
to these characters.
I think they're tremendously
nuanced characters, all of whom
transform in a number of ways,
probably none more notable
than your
transformation, Bradley.
You go from perhaps a bit vain
and perhaps a bit unconcerned
about anything--
I think even Glinda, she may
be a bit vain, but scatty.
But she already has this
heart, whereas you start
in a very different place.
How do you manage
that transition?
BRADLEY JADEN:
Well, this is funny
because I don't see
Fiyero as arrogant.
I think that he has his
own brand of cavalier,
and he has his kind of--
he has his own ways.
But he's so different
from all the rest
of the other people in Shiz.
But how do we know that
he's not the same as where
he is as other people
from where he comes from?
In Winky Land?
And they're all kind of
that place in their life.
And he's just coming, and
he's just like, hey, this
is how I am.
And I'm just quite
relaxed and chilled.
And all these other
people kind of
go, wow, this is so different.
And like you said, he
goes on a massive journey.
And he turns up, and he's
never met women as powerful
as these two.
And I think he learns
so much about himself
throughout the show.
And I think that's
so exciting that he's
challenged by these
powerful women,
and he's taken on
a journey that he
can find the truth in himself.
I think he's, in a way,
learned and grown up
to be a certain way through--
I don't know-- peer pressure
or the way the society is,
that to meet these women
that can change his life
and allow him to be that honest
and that truthful to himself,
that's exciting.
And I think that's the way
I kind of want it to play,
that the audience
can kind of say that,
oh, yeah, you're not afraid
to be open with your emotions,
and to go as far as you can, and
wear your heart on your sleeve.
SPEAKER: I love it.
And I think perhaps I've made
some unfair assumptions here.
BRADLEY JADEN: No,
no, not at all.
Of course, I think
everyone does always
say he's arrogant
because he does turn up,
and he has that song and he
gets everyone to dance his way.
But I think he's just carefree.
I think he's just
out having a laugh.
And he doesn't want--
he's not telling people,
you have to do this.
There's no time he ever
says you have to do it.
He's just saying,
let's just give it--
just give it a go.
SPEAKER: Exactly.
And I think there's a real-- so
I just made this mistake now.
I've made some assumptions
about the character.
And I think one of
the perhaps most
interesting things
about "Wicked"
is the fact that we go to
this world, we go to Oz,
and we're making all
kinds of assumptions.
And the opening number,
we're making assumptions
about Glinda and the good
witch, and Elphie, who's
the Wicked Witch of the West.
And what does this
mean, without actually
knowing the background.
ALICE FEARN: Well that's it.
That's the whole show is
that from that instant,
if you've made an assumption
that Elphaba is a wicked witch.
And that's the whole point
of the story is to say,
your assumptions were
completely wrong and fueled
by gossip and propaganda.
So yeah, that's
the entire thing is
that you do assume that
Fiyero is maybe vain,
or you do assume
that she's wicked.
And you assume all those things.
And actually, that's
the whole point.
By the end of it, you go, wow,
I think I was completely wrong.
BRADLEY JADEN:
And that's why I--
sorry, I'll go back because I
get excited by this question.
When you are presumed something,
it's the same as the poster.
When you look at the
poster, in this day and age,
you see "Wicked."
And you see the green witch.
And you see the white witch.
But not one part
of it does it say,
the good and the bad witch.
Do you know?
I mean, you could
actually say, well,
why is the white
witch whispering?
That's a bad trait.
Do you know what I mean?
The green witch--
why is the green bad,
when in certain countries,
green is a lucky color?
Why is wicked bad?
When in this day and age,
people wake up and you go,
ah, that's wicked.
That's cool.
So there's so many different--
do you know what I mean?
Like, there's so
many different things
that you look at
that poster and go,
why, in this part
of our life, do we
see that as a negative, as that
green person is the negative?
And that's what is so
exciting about "Wicked,"
that by the end of it,
you have completely
changed all your expectations.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
And in some of the
posters, you can also--
the white witch is not
entirely visible either, right?
So you've got this
really interesting moment
where you think, well,
what is going on?
BRADLEY JADEN: Yeah.
SPEAKER: We don't know.
SOPHIE EVANS: No idea
what is going on.
SPEAKER: And so--
ALICE FEARN: I think,
why are you whispering?
A good question for me.
BRADLEY JADEN: How do
you feel about that?
ALICE FEARN: What
are you whispering?
SPEAKER: So I would love to know
the answer to that question.
So I feel like if there are
any two people in the world who
can answer that question,
they're right here on stage.
SOPHIE EVANS: I'm hungry.
ALICE FEARN: Which is what
we are at this moment.
I'm absolutely starving
after that three hours.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: I think that brings us
to a slightly lighter question,
which is, how do you prepare?
And how do you keep the energy
for such a demanding run
of shows?
SOPHIE EVANS: I like to not
have any rituals or anything.
Because I know there
are some performers that
have a certain thing they do.
But I'm not the one
that wants to create
those things because then when
you're not able to do those--
like make sure you have
10 minutes with your eyes
closed or anything like--
I don't believe in it.
So I just have a
normal day, wake up,
have breakfast and then,
go in and do the show.
Keep it cazh.
ALICE FEARN: Keep it cazh.
I don't-- I don't tend to do a
marathon or anything before it.
I do tend to rest to some
degree during the day.
I think my--
I've always loved sleep.
But I do definitely--
if I've had a bad
night's sleep, it's
a somewhat bad show, or
a difficult show for me.
I think if I don't get a
really good night's sleep,
I do find that my voice can
tend to have a hard time.
And I find that my
energy level is low.
I don't worry about what
I eat at the minute,
not that I ever really did.
But you know what I mean?
I'm like, yeah, if it's a
huge pasta, it's a huge pasta.
And that's what it is.
With extra garlic bread?
That's fine because I'm
going to work it off
in three hours of running
around in those black outfits.
So, yeah I don't overthink it.
I think people who've gone
before me, if they have,
I think they actually probably
find it harder if you overthink
and of worry too much about it.
At the end of the day,
it's not heart surgery,
as we always say.
You're not saving lives.
You're just trying to make
someone's life that day
a bit happier.
So you just got to
remember that, really.
But yeah, I'm the same.
I don't have an
awful lot of rituals.
I just like eight hours.
SOPHIE EVANS: Yeah.
ALICE FEARN: Yeah, that's it.
SPEAKER: Well, given the number
of shows you do per week,
I can see why you
need your sleep.
And I can see why extra energy
from pasta or extra garlic--
ALICE FEARN: Yeah, oh, god.
Get the carbs in.
Yup.
SPEAKER: Bradley,
what about you?
BRADLEY JADEN: Well,
I do have to watch
what I eat just because
otherwise, I'm not going
to get in those little tights.
[LAUGHTER]
That's going to be a
sight for sore eyes.
So yeah, I do go to
the gym every day.
And I like to eat
quite healthily.
Other than that, I don't
really sleep that much anyway.
So I don't need that.
And then, I just like
to play some loud music
before I go on, really,
just to get in the mood
and have a bit of a dance about.
I'm not sure the
creatives always
like it when they knock
on the dressing room door,
and they're like, trying to give
me a note, and I'm like, yeah!
SPEAKER: Now, the
follow-on question clearly
is what music are you
listening to that causes people
to say, oh, what's going on?
ALICE FEARN: You got
quite an eclectic--
BRADLEY JADEN: Yeah, I
mean, I have quite a range.
I will listen to everything.
before a show, I do
quite like listening
to a bit of hip-hop and grime.
SOPHIE EVANS: Yup.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
Amazing.
ALICE FEARN:
Hip-hop and grime, I
don't even know what grime is.
Hip-hop and grime.
BRADLEY JADEN: So yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: I could talk
about grime for hours.
ALICE FEARN: Could you?
SPEAKER: Oh, yeah, yeah.
ALICE FEARN: I don't even--
SOPHIE EVANS: Sing us a bit.
I haven't got a clue either.
BRADLEY JADEN:
I'll play you some.
SOPHIE EVANS: OK.
SPEAKER: OK, OK.
So perhaps, after
the show, we'll
all listen to some
hip-hop and grime.
SOPHIE EVANS: I'll
type that into iTunes.
BRADLEY JADEN: Yeah.
ALICE FEARN: Grime.
SOPHIE EVANS: Type
it into Google.
ALICE FEARN: Eh!
SPEAKER: Exactly, exactly.
So we've talked a
little bit about how
it's a female-centered show.
And you brought
that up, Bradley.
But what's it like actually
playing these tremendously
interesting, complex women?
SOPHIE EVANS: Amazing.
I actually feel like you
teach an audience things
that you learned in the show.
I learned stuff about being
a woman throughout the show,
and how--
if you've not seen
the show, Glinda,
she's from a
background where she
gets everything her own way.
And she thinks that's how
life's always going to be.
And she goes to school.
And you find out
that school isn't
as easy as being at home with
your lovely mother and father
who give you everything.
So you learn that you don't
always get your own way.
And I think that's a great
lesson to teach people, young--
I love it when
children come because I
think children look at it
a different way to adults
as well.
So to impose those
lessons is quite special.
And I learn all the
time in the show.
So, yeah, it's special.
SPEAKER: Wonderful.
ALICE FEARN: Well, Elphaba,
the part is a fight.
You're constantly fighting from
the moment you get on stage.
So it's, in many ways, the
draining sort of quality
that you have at
the end of the show,
especially in "For Good" is
very real because of the fight
that you're constantly-- you're
playing for 2 and 1/2 hours.
The fight to well, be normal is
from the second she walks on.
So I find it draining in
a really positive way,
if that's a thing.
Because that fight
brings out, actually,
wonderful things for her, a
friendship that she'll never
forget, the love of her life.
So she gets a lot
out of those fights
as well as losing an awful
lot at the same time.
But the story-- we always get
quite emotional by "For Good."
And I think it's because we
have been through an awful lot,
and we've played our
stories full out.
We've really gone
through the motions
and really had to emote.
Yeah, and I think fight is
the classic word for me.
We go through so much that
that is an amazing sort
of feeling to play.
And although we might be
tired, and although we
might need to eat a giant
pasta at the end of the show,
it feels like you've really--
it's really worth it for
the story that you've told.
And to try and change
people's perspectives on it,
that it's really nice
that, to sort of go,
you didn't think that was
going to happen, did you?
Or you didn't think she
was like that, did you?
Really good.
I'm really pleased that you
have come out going, oh, my god.
There was one show recently
that I popped up at the--
we were at the very end.
And everyone's
just, like, oh yay!
And like, everyone
just went, ah!
And it in that moment, you
just go, yeah, thanks, guys.
You were with us.
You know?
And when you have moments
like that, it's just great.
And yeah, it's really--
it's such a ride.
It's such an exhausting ride.
But it's so worth
it for every moment
you get from the audience.
SOPHIE EVANS: I think one of
the other biggest lessons,
especially at the
end of the show when
you listen to "For Good,"
is about forgiveness
and forgiving
friends because we've
got such a strong
friendship in the show.
We come over all the hurdles
of not liking each other.
And then we actually
realize we are
two complete different people
who just love each other
because we're so different.
And then we have
all these things.
She runs off with the
love of my life as well,
not to give the story away, but
that is giving the story away.
But then at the end, you
realize that friendship
is more important
than forgiveness
and that we do have
a strong bond that's
more important than the things
that have tried to separate us.
ALICE FEARN: Yup.
SPEAKER: Exactly.
And that real life
is messy, right?
Nobody is perfectly good,
and nobody is perfectly evil.
ALICE FEARN: Yeah,
no life is perfect.
SOPHIE EVANS: So true.
ALICE FEARN: And it's how you--
and it's how you deal
with that and come out
the other end that's the
most important thing, which
is exactly what this story is.
SOPHIE EVANS: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Super.
What do you like most and
least about your characters?
ALICE FEARN: Most and least?
Go on, Brad.
BRADLEY JADEN: Oh, OK.
Yeah, OK.
SPEAKER: So clearly,
you're gorgeous.
Right?
Like, let's be [STUTTERS].
BRADLEY JADEN: Oh.
Oh.
ALICE FEARN: You are?
BRADLEY JADEN: Hello.
Oh, goodness.
I don't know.
I do love the way that he just--
I think the carefree
way of life.
I think I've learned a lot.
And that sounds a bit
weird to say that you've
learned a lot from a character.
But I've learned
a lot about myself
through playing Fiyero
and just allowing yourself
to be a bit more relaxed, and
taking each day as it comes,
and being a bit more carefree.
And if people say, do
you want to do this,
you go, yeah rather
than just being uptight.
And I think, in our business
as well, like Alice said,
you can get so like,
I need to do this.
I need to be
perfect every night.
And I need to-- your
standard's still there.
But you got to give
yourself a bit of a break
in all kind of walks of life.
You know?
Like, as actors,
obviously, we care so much.
But you want to be
perfect every time.
And sometimes you can't.
Do you know what I mean?
And I think I've
learned a lot from that.
And then his negative.
So I don't know.
Maybe his choice
of clothing maybe.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, that's
something to be--
yeah, I'll say maybe that.
SOPHIE EVANS: I like
his tight pants.
I think they look great.
BRADLEY JADEN: But I mean, I
mean, I'm in lady's jeans now
so I can't really complain.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: I don't know
how you top that one.
I'm just saying.
ALICE FEARN: I like--
because I don't
think it's a trait
that I actually
have as a person.
So I like that she will stand
up no matter what and say
when something is wrong.
I'm someone that tends
to go, I don't like that,
but I'm going to think
what would happen
if I say that I don't like it.
And I think of the options
that would happen afterwards.
Elphaba doesn't.
It's like, I don't like that.
I'm saying something about it.
She doesn't think of the
consequences of those.
And although that might
mean a lot of bad stuff
happens to her during
the show for that reason,
I think that's an amazing
thing to just go, no,
I don't believe in that,
or I don't trust that,
and that's wrong.
And so I'm going to instantly
say something about that.
I think that's amazing.
Her negatives-- she just
runs around too much,
and it's tiring.
She's just like, it's constant.
It's just never-ending.
That's the only negative.
I think she's a
brilliant character.
And I think there's
a lot of things
that I'd love to take
from her in life.
There's not many--
I don't even see being
green as a negative.
BRADLEY JADEN: I don't think
there are negatives to the both
of the girls.
ALICE FEARN: I don't
think that even
being green I see as a negative.
I think it's fabulous.
I mean, in fact, I think
I look better green.
SOPHIE EVANS: You
look fantastic green.
ALICE FEARN: I do.
I look better green.
SPEAKER: We'll come back
to green in a second.
But I would love
to know what Sophie
has to say about her character.
SOPHIE EVANS: My character,
I love how happy she is.
I'm a very smiley, happy person.
So I love that I get
to be that on stage.
Sometimes when you're
feeling a bit tired,
it is hard to be smiley.
And my face, at the start of
the run, I had to get a massage.
My face was killing because
I'm constantly like this.
So I couldn't get it down.
I was like, I'm stuck.
[LAUGHTER]
So I love that.
I love that I get to
be happy and positive.
The only negative for me,
it's related to the costumes.
They are so heavy that my
body is a bit sore, sore.
That's the only thing.
If I could just make them
a little bit lighter.
SPEAKER: They are
tremendous costumes.
SOPHIE EVANS: They're amazing.
SPEAKER: And for those of you
who haven't seen the show,
like, I don't know how
you move in those skirts.
Right?
ALICE FEARN: Oh, my god.
They're enormous.
SOPHIE EVANS: Yeah, I know.
The skirt is.
And it's so tight.
And it's right on your hips,
and it pulls right down.
And the stage is like this.
And I'm in heels.
So my body's just a bit,
like, what are you doing?
But I look great.
It's fine.
SPEAKER: Yeah, exactly.
They're gorgeous,
absolutely gorgeous.
So you're green, Alice,
when you're Elphaba.
But you're not
green at the moment.
You look very nice.
But you do seem to have
green nail varnish on.
ALICE FEARN: Yeah, because
I've got to have green nails.
SPEAKER: Exactly.
What's the makeup routine like?
And then how do
you get it all off?
ALICE FEARN: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
With a challenge.
If you look closely,
I'm sure you'll
go-- oh, actually, you've not
doing very well getting it off
last night.
But so I have to get in a
bit earlier than everyone.
So I have to get in about half
an hour earlier than everyone
to start the makeup routine.
And Act One is a little bit
slightly different to Act Two
makeup.
So they don't have to do
an awful lot of eye makeup
on me, for instance.
It's quite literally just green,
really, and a bit of mascara.
And then Act Two,
it gets much darker.
And so they've sort
of-- it's not too bad.
I thought it was going to
be much worse than the time
that it takes.
They've got it down to
a fine art, I think.
How do I get it off?
Weirdly, baby shampoo
works really, really well.
Don't know what's
in baby shampoo.
But you just get basically
a scrubbing brush and baby
shampoo, and you go for
it for about 10 minutes.
And it all eventually comes off.
It is water-based makeup so
it is willing to come off.
But yeah, I mean,
after a two-show day,
that's really bedded into
that skin and those pores.
So I think it wasn't
that long ago, actually,
and after a two-show day,
I had a really full shower,
like a good 20 minutes, scrubbed
everything off, went home,
and Guv went--
he's my partner, by the way.
He went, oh, not done very
well getting it off tonight.
Did you rush?
And, like, a single tear
trickles down my face
as I went, no, I just spent
20 minutes in the shower.
So sometimes, it
depends on, I think,
how long you've had
it on for that day.
But yeah, it does come off
if you're stable enough
to go through the scrubbing.
But the skin suffers slightly.
But that's just-- it's worth it.
SPEAKER: For the arts.
We're going to turn to audience
questions in a few minutes.
I've got one more that
I'd like to ask the cast.
If you have a question,
please go to the microphone
in the center of the room now.
So I've got kind of, I
guess, a general acting
question about your most
memorable moments on stage,
whether it's in this
show or perhaps another.
What are they?
ALICE FEARN: During the show?
SPEAKER: Any show.
Is it this show?
Is it one of your
first shows, maybe when
you were starting out?
SOPHIE EVANS: I've got--
it's related to
"Wicked," because it's
"The Wizard of Oz."
It's children that I was in.
I was doing the show.
And obviously, we
had a real life dog.
I was Dorothy in "The Wizard
of Oz," which was brilliant.
We had a real life dog, Toto,
who was very well-behaved most
of the time.
But one show, he must've had,
like, spicy dinner or something
because he decided to go
to the toilet on stage.
And a little munchkin had to
run off, get a little pooper
scooper, run back on.
And he stole the show.
Yeah, so--
ALICE FEARN: Bet he got
a round of applause.
SOPHIE EVANS: He always
got the biggest applause
at the end of the show.
He'd run on.
He did nothing.
I just fed him ham
the whole show.
And he got the applause.
That was fun.
ALICE FEARN: I
can't think of one.
Can you?
BRADLEY JADEN: Not most.
ALICE FEARN: I can
only think of things
that have gone wrong in my
past, in different shows,
like people--
like things not
working or something.
That's all I can think of.
SPEAKER: But even
then, I think there's
a question around
resilience, right?
How do you bounce
back from that?
How do you take that
to something positive?
ALICE FEARN: I don't let it
get to me too much if something
goes wrong.
You have to sort
of brush it off.
Because if you get
annoyed about it,
then it's going to get sort
of like-- pointless energy.
BRADLEY JADEN: That's what
exciting about live theater.
Do you know what I mean?
That's--
SPEAKER: Yeah.
BRADLEY JADEN: It keeps it
fresh for you and the audience,
you know.
And it's your job
to hopefully make
sure the audience are not aware
of a mistake that does happen.
But things happen.
But like you said, it's not
our job to try [INAUDIBLE]..
ALICE FEARN: Once there wasn't
a wig-- when I was in "Shrek."
This is in "Shrek."
I pointed to Bradley because
we did "Shrek" together, "Shrek
the Musical."
And yeah, there wasn't a wig.
And I was doing this
really quick change.
And this fear that suddenly
crossed the wig lady, Paula.
And she just went,
I've not got your wig!
And I just went,
let's improvise.
And so I got this, like,
shawl that was on the set.
And I just went, don't worry.
I'll just use this
because we had no time
to go and get a wig.
And so we just
threw this around.
I just went and did this
scene and then came back off.
And she just was, like, in
tears, going, I'm so sorry.
And I was just like, that
was quite fun for me.
I made it work.
It's things like that I quite
like as long as they're not
dangerous.
And no one will have noticed.
I don't think anyone noticed.
I think I even had
people in that night.
And I went, oh, did
you see me with no wig?
And they were like, don't know
what you're talking about.
We always notice it
way more, because we
know it's not the norm.
But actually, an audience
very, very rarely,
unless they are there every sort
of day, which there are some
that are and would notice it.
I generally quite
like it if things
go wrong because it
makes me go, how do I
deal with the situation?
What do I have to do?
And improvise.
SOPHIE EVANS: You have
to use your brain.
ALICE FEARN: Yeah, you have
to use your brain suddenly.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
Bradley, any memorable moments?
And then we've got some
questions from the audience.
BRADLEY JADEN: Yeah, I mean,
obviously, you get those ones.
But then there's
also those times
where as actors, when
you've been working hard
to get to your dreams--
and we've all been
understudies as well.
And when we get that
chance to go on--
I remember the first time
I ever played Jean Valjean.
And I cried for,
like, two hours.
Do you know what I mean?
I was just-- I've
played Jean Valjean.
And my mom was there and stuff.
But then I remember when you get
the phone call to play Fiyero.
I was just-- you get so
overwhelmed because your dream
is coming true.
So you have those memorable
moments where things go wrong,
and you have to deal with it.
But then you get those
moments of pure elation
where you're just kind of
like, wow, it's happened.
And that's what's exciting
about being a performer
and an actor at the moment.
SPEAKER: Amazing.
Let's turn it over to the
audience questions now.
AUDIENCE: My question is around
backstage and how confusing
it is and how organized it
is because there's monkeys
everywhere.
There's scores of changes.
BRADLEY JADEN: Like a zoo.
Like, they're just
running around--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering
what goes backstage?
SOPHIE EVANS: Oh
it's like a circus.
But in a good way.
I very much--
BRADLEY JADEN: It's
controlled chaos.
SOPHIE EVANS: I've got
some really quick changes.
And the work that goes on
backstage-- so when I come off,
the first time I leave the
stage in the big bubble dress,
I then have to get changed
into this little suit
to be a student at Shiz.
And there's about six people
just taking my wig off, taking
my shoes off, taking my
dress off, putting me
in a different costume.
And it happens in about--
it must be about five,
six seconds because I've
got time to spare
where I can have
a drink and things like that.
And it's just amazing.
The people backstage
are so on it.
It's so rehearsed and
so well thought through.
BRADLEY JADEN: I think if
you saw it as an outsider,
you would literally think
it was absolutely crazy.
And it is chaos.
But it's like a
well-oiled machine.
And like Sophie said, we've got
an incredible backstage crew
and wigs and costume.
And everyone knows their job.
And everyone's doing their
track to their best ability.
And everything just
moves so fluid.
ALICE FEARN: You
can't really have,
like, someone come
and stand in the wings
and watch because
that will instantly
disrupt the flow of the things
coming off, people coming off.
They've got certain
directions they
need to go to get a
really quick change done.
As soon as they
pass, then someone
brings something over here.
Then that something's flying
up, something's coming in.
If you're in that way,
then you can't be.
So you just can't--
it's perfectly-- I mean, now,
it's a well-oiled machine.
But it's all perfectly planned.
This is why techs are there.
We have a technical rehearsal
always before shows.
And that's why they're
there is to work out
how this can work
perfectly and what
needs to happen at what point.
So yes, it does look like
a madhouse, absolutely.
But from our eyes, we
know exactly what--
you can see what's going on.
It's amazing.
It's very well done.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: I can't-- I imagine--
the Apollo's an old theater,
right?
So I imagine there's not a lot
of space back there either,
which makes it even more--
ALICE FEARN: Oh, I've worked
in much less space actually.
I actually think it's quite--
I mean, there is
a lot of scenery.
And there is a lot of
set that has to go up
in order to really space down.
So yeah, they use height as
opposed to width and depth
maybe.
But again, it's just
perfectly timed so well.
You wouldn't notice.
I never even notice
what they're doing.
It's amazing.
SPEAKER: Amazing, amazing.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
ALICE FEARN: Hi.
SPEAKER: I'm interested
to know what happens
once the show is all finished.
So do you start
auditioning for a new show?
Or do you have some downtime?
Or do you travel with the show?
Or yeah--
SOPHIE EVANS: It can be
any of those options.
ALICE FEARN: Yeah.
Actually, all of
them or none of them.
SOPHIE EVANS: You don't know.
We would all, I assume--
unless you want a
bit of time off--
audition for a new show, or TV,
or whatever you wanted to do.
But there's no guarantee
you'll ever work again really.
[LAUGHTER]
ALICE FEARN: There isn't.
There really isn't.
SOPHIE EVANS: There's not.
it's really fickle.
But--
ALICE FEARN: Yeah.
You've always got a contract so
you always know your end date,
as it were, whether that extends
further than that, you just
don't know.
So yeah, as you
get closer to that,
if something is available
after that end date,
then yeah, you start
auditioning for it,
with the just sincere
hope that you get it.
I do always like--
I've been working for
about 13 years now.
And I always go through
a phase that once I'm
getting towards the end of a
job, I want my evenings back.
And I start going,
I really can't
wait to watch "Coronation
Street" at 7:30.
You know what I mean?
So you sort of get that feeling.
And you go, oh, I'm going
to do that for a while.
And maybe you fill your day
with whatever work you do,
sessions or whatever items.
I teach a lot.
And then I do that
for a couple of weeks.
And I go, now, I'm ready to
give my life back to a show
again now.
Do you know what I mean?
So I go through that cycle
every single time pretty much.
And I've done that
every single time.
If someone said to me, Alice,
you finish on Saturday night,
and Monday, you start
that, I'd be like, oh, OK.
[FAKE CRIES]
Because actually,
that's not ideal for me.
I do like to have
a bit of a break,
not because I don't
love theater in any way.
Just because I think
it's good for the brain
to have that change
up because it
makes you appreciate each time
when you go back into a show.
That's just my thing.
BRADLEY JADEN: Well,
to touch on that,
I mean, I've been
very, very, very lucky
since I did "Shrek" with Alice.
I did "Shrek."
And then I finished
that on a Saturday.
And on the Monday,
I started "Ghost."
I finished that on the Saturday.
And I started "Les
Mis" on the Monday.
And then, I did that, and
then did the "Wicked" on tour
and then finished that, and
went straight into this.
So I actually, since
we did "Shrek" in 2012,
I've not had a--
ALICE FEARN: (SINGING)
Someone's talented.
BRADLEY JADEN: But it's just
been a lucky thing because--
ALICE FEARN: (SINGING) Very
talented, just really more
talented than you are.
OK?
[LAUGHTER]
SOPHIE EVANS: Well
done, Bradley.
BRADLEY JADEN: It's not that!
I'm just saying--
ALICE FEARN: What can I say?
BRADLEY JADEN: But
I would sometimes
really like a bit of down time
and watch "Coronation Street."
ALICE FEARN: Stop
being so talented!
[LAUGHTER]
Getting all the jobs
from everyone else.
BRADLEY JADEN: No, but yeah.
I don't know.
There could be a job
that starts on a Monday.
That's what I'll say.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: What's the ramp
up into a new show like?
So because you're talented,
you stop on Saturday,
and you start again on Monday.
[LAUGHTER]
Into shows that have been
running for a long time,
how do you ramp up?
How do you get going?
How does that work?
BRADLEY JADEN: Well, usually,
you either double up,
or you start up.
So you would do maybe four weeks
of a different show in the day,
and then you would do
your show in the evening,
of a different show.
ALICE FEARN: Yeah.
And the brain.
SOPHIE EVANS: That never
happened to me though.
BRADLEY JADEN: Or
if you're doing
that, even if you're doing a
cast change, when people have
stayed on for "Wicked" and
stuff and doing an extra year,
you'll be doing--
you rehearse with the
new cast in the daytime
until 5 o'clock or 4:30.
Then you have a couple of hours
off, and then you do your show.
And that would happen
for four to five weeks.
If you are lucky, and maybe
it is a different show
that actually the rehearsals
start on the Monday,
then you're quite lucky that
you have the evenings free.
But it is a bit of
a jigsaw, I think,
between the shows
and your rehearsals
and how it's kind
of placed, really.
ALICE FEARN: I think sometimes,
when you're doing a new show,
or you're rehearsing something,
your brain instantly goes--
because we're creative minds.
We've got creative--
so actually,
it's really nice because
you go, oh, my god.
I'm thinking about
something else.
I'm thinking about a new
story, a new character,
new intentions, new drives.
So actually, sometimes it can
be really quite beneficial
if you've done something
for a long time
because it does wake you back up
again to being a bit creative.
SPEAKER: Oh, super.
And one last question.
AUDIENCE: What would be your
dream role on stage that you've
not had the chance to play?
SOPHIE EVANS: "The Little
Mermaid" would be mine.
SPEAKER: Oh.
SOPHIE EVANS: But she
has to roller skate.
And as I've said,
I'm really clumsy.
So I don't know if
that's a good idea.
[LAUGHTER]
I'd love to try.
ALICE FEARN: Elphaba
was a big one for me.
It had been for
many, many years.
To be honest, a part
that I'd love to play
is one that I can never play
because it's a man's role.
But I would love to play
Jean Valjean in "Les Mis."
If we could just ignore the
fact that I was a woman,
that would be the part
that I'd choose to play.
BRADLEY JADEN: Yeah.
Well, I was very lucky
enough to play that role.
And that was always a dream.
ALICE FEARN: Yeah,
it's all right for you.
BRADLEY JADEN: But
if anything else,
I'd love to play the Phantom in
"Phantom of the Opera" one day.
ALICE FEARN: Next
job, let's face it.
You've just said it now.
And you're so talented,
you'll start on the Monday!
BRADLEY JADEN: I'll start
on the Monday, everyone!
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: But I do hope to see
you continue in your roles
in "Wicked" for perhaps
a little longer yet.
"Wicked" is at the Apollo
Theater near Victoria.
Many, many thanks
to Sophie Evans--
SOPHIE EVANS: Thank you.
ALICE FEARN: Alice
Fearn, and Bradley Jaden.
[APPLAUSE]
SOPHIE EVANS: The
really talented one.
SPEAKER: Thank you very
much for joining us.
I think the cast will pose
for some pictures now.
Thank you.
ALICE FEARN: Thank you.
BRADLEY JADEN: Thank you.